JILLIAN: WE ARE BACK WITH A FOX
NEWS ALERT REPUBLICANS CALLING
FOR ANDREW CUOMO TO BE REMOVED
FROM OFFICE AFTER THE NEW YORK
POST REPORTS ONE OF HIS AIDES
ADMITTED TO COVERING OF DATA ON
NURSING HOME DEATHS.
TODD: 15,000 NURSING HOME
PATIENTS HAVE DIED OF COVID-19
NEW YORK STATE UP FROM 8500
PREVIOUSLY REPORTED.
JILLIAN: SECRETARY TO THE
GOVERNOR MADE COMMENTS ABOUT
HIGHER TOTAL DURING A VIDEO CALL
WHILE TRYING TO EXPLAIN WHY THE
ACTUAL NUMBERS HELPED.
TODD: JANICE SEEN LOST BOTH OF
HER IN-LAWS TO THE PANDEMIC LAST
YEAR AND JOINED US TO REACT.
THERE HAVE BEEN A FEW BOMBSHELL
SITTING CUOMO ON THIS RECENTLY.
IS THIS THE MOST DAMNING?
>> THIS IS THE MOST DAMNING
BECAUSE SOMEONE ADMITTED IT AND
REPORTED IT AND IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY COVERED IT UP THE WHOLE
TIME AND THE FACT THEY HAD A
CLOSED-DOOR MEETING WITH
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS TO
APOLOGIZE TO THEM INSTEAD OF THE
PEOPLE WHO DON’T HAVE THEIR
LOVED ONES TODAY IS JUST ICING
ON THE CAKE.
JILLIAN: HOW EMOTIONAL WAS IT
WHEN YOU HEARD THIS NEWS?
>> JANICE: EMOTIONAL.
I DIDN’T THINK I COULD BE MORE
SURPRISE THAN A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
WITH THE AG REPORT IN NEW YORK
WHERE SHE WENT AHEAD AND
INVESTIGATED THE GOVERNOR INTO
NURSING HOME NUMBERS WHICH WE
ALL DO -- NEW WERE UNDERCOUNTED.
THEY WERE REPORTING OVER 6000
FOR MANY MONTHS AND NOW WE ARE
UP TO 15,000.
ANOTHER PART OF THAT BOMBSHELL
IS OVER 9000 INFECTED PATIENTS
WERE PUT INTO NURSING HOMES AND
THEY TRIED TO DISMISS THAT AS
THE CAUSE OF THE ELDER THAT WE
LOST IN NURSING HOMES IN THE
SPRING, SO THE FACT THEY HAVE
ADMITTED THIS, MY HAT IS OFF TO
THE LEAKER.
AND DOING HEROIC WORK, AND THAT
IS WHY I AM SO VOCAL.
FIRST STEP INTO IN-LAWS.
TODD: WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU
ABOUT THE PEOPLE INVOLVED, THE
INSTINCT IN TERMS OF AN APOLOGY
WAS TO THE DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS
WHO COULD BE POTENTIALLY HURT BY
THIS REVELATION?
WHEN THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO NEVER
SEE FAMILY MEMBERS OF HER AGAIN
BUT ARE WORRIED ABOUT A STATE
SENATOR IN ON MY RIGHT?
>> LOOK AT THIS GOVERNOR’S TRACK
RECORD, HIS LEADERSHIP, HIS EMMY
AWARD.
ONLY HIMSELF AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
WE NEVER GOT AN APOLOGY FOR ANY
REMORSE FROM THIS GOVERNOR.
I BELIEVE HE SHOULD BE IN JAIL.
JILLIAN: I WAS GOING TO SAY WHAT
DO YOU THINK SHOULD HAPPEN?
COURT OF LAW, FULL
INVESTIGATION, THE WHOLE TRUTH